so um at the end of the dark world Loki
is on the throne the beginning of
Ragnarok Thor has a few questions and
Loki is enduringly enigmatic about
providing answers Taika Waititi is such
a spirited hilarious individual and he
and Chris became very fast friends and I
what was great for me to do is to see
their friendship kind of blossom and
they brought out the best in each other
and started making stuff up and I can
confidently say right now this would be
the funniest depiction of the character
of saw that you'd ever seen I have known
for almost 10 years with Chris Hemsworth
his hilarious I think this go-around
will be his chart
hey everybody is Charlie so Tom
Hiddleston dropped a whole bunch of
extra information about Ragnarok in
addition to the stuff that's in this
clip someone to do a breakdown the
tagline is that he basically craps his
pants at the site of hella so he runs to
Thor and that's sort of where he picks
up in this teaser here Thor has a lot of
questions
Loki isn't very forthcoming about
answers so if you're brand new to the
channel I do Marvel videos every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything
I'm even doing a Doctor Strange DVD
giveaway in speaking of which I'm going
to have to reference some stuff from the
end of that movie so just be careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen Doctor
Strange yet a lot of this is all taken
from interviews that he's been doing for
his Kong Skull Island movie so he goes
on to say this is stuff that wasn't in
that clip but hammers are involved in
stakes are raised so I'm paraphrasing
him Kate Blanchet it's no secret is
playing the goddess of death who brings
destruction in her wake and it's the
kind of destruction that both Thor and
Loki have never seen on a scale of
terror that they've never seen before so
they fall back on their Brotherhood so
that's actually a really big thing
fractured though it is to see what they
can do to stop her that's the Loki Thor
through-line so you have to imagine that
they both like each other
remember that funny Captain America
scene where Loki puts on the costume
like he makes himself look like Captain
America maybe you'd rather have one of
your Avengers friends with you on this
journey so he really likes that I mean
he likes to torment Thor the way that
brothers torment each other so even
though he has all these feelings of
being an outsider being an outcast
because he is part frost giant he still
feels this very brotherly bond with door
it'll come through in the movie in a way
that I don't think that it came through
during dark world you felt a little bit
of their camaraderie but a lot of the
characters got lost in that movie and I
think that that's why Thor Ragnarok like
one of the big reasons why it's going to
be a lot better because they're focusing
more on the characters but they've also
got all that crazy spectacle - they got
the planet hold stuff they have hello
they have Ragnarok itself but tracing
the through line from what Tom
Hiddleston said to the official synopsis
of the movie Thor imprisoned on the
other side of the universe without his
mighty hammer and finds himself in a
race against time to get back to Asgard
to stop Ragnarok the destruction of his
home world in the end of as
guardians civilization at the hands of
an all-powerful new threat
the ruthless Ella but first he must
survive a deadly gladiatorial contests
that pits them against his former ally
and fellow Avenger the Incredible Hulk
so between all the teasers they've been
dropping recently between the concept
footage the infinity war stuff we've
actually seen a bunch of thor ragnarok
so far and even if you have like a broad
idea of Jack Kirby's storyline you know
that it's the destruction of Asgard
where some of the Gods live some of them
die and are reborn as new versions of
themselves so there's this endless cycle
of death and rebirth in the universe I
don't know how they're going to explain
that in the movies they might make her
more of an Angela character because
that's kind of the vibe that she's
giving up but she herself is part frost
giant just like Loki in her power is so
great that they might even tune it down
just a little bit in the movies she has
the ability to Cole the actual souls of
a certain percentage of dead as
guardians so if you don't know who
Angela is she's actually a pretty cool
character that Neil Gaiman created that
belonged to Dark Horse for a while Todd
McFarlane there was this big legal
battle but he got her back
so Marvel started using her in made her
the daughter of Odin the lost daughter
of Odin so she's basically just a super
badass character imagine her being like
a much crazier version of Gamora like
you see Gamora and the guardians trailer
holding this giant weapon
just imagine Angela holding two of those
at the same time but she mostly uses
swords in the context of the comics
there's this other realm called heaven
which is the tenth realm that Odin
sealed off and erased all records of but
they were able to steal one of his
children when they escaped so Angela
comes back later seeking her revenge
against Odin and the forces of Asgard
having her mind be a little bit twisted
hell a story in the comics is kind of
like that too except it's more of a
Lucifer type story like imagine Lucifer
getting banished to hell and forced to
preside over all those souls
so hella is really pissed but she gains
all these extra powers so the way they
explain her in the movie so far the
synopsis that we've gotten is that she's
seeking Ragnarok the destruction of all
of the nine realms
not just Asgardian Society
but the way they've been teasing it so
far they're just talking about the
destruction of Asgardian society but it
really it's much bigger than that
because if Loki didn't crap his pants
when the Dark Elves started to destroy
Asgard you have to imagine that
something that would make him crap his
pants is way way worse so that is where
we get to Ragnarok which is sort of the
pre lewd for infinity war because Thanos
is trying to do the same thing on a
universal scale you have to imagine like
Doctor Strange hops between different
dimensions there's a different Infinity
Gauntlet between different realities so
multiverse many Infinity Gauntlet many
versions of Thanos try to erase all life
so we're not quite there yet we're sort
of localized to the MCU six one six or
whatever you want to call it like the
single universe Dormammu is sort of
waiting in the wings for phase four
stuff is going to be happening later on
speaking of Doctor Strange stuff so the
funny thing that Tom Hiddleston said is
that Loki is completely unimpressed with
dr. Strange's sorcery he's like oh
that's cool but I've been doing that for
centuries so what's the big deal so even
though he doesn't appear in that Thor
post-credit scene he will probably
appear with Doctor Strange on screen in
Thor Ragnarok because they want to hold
something back for the actual movie in
the whole point of that post-credit
scene was it just show you what the
dynamics is going to be like with Doctor
Strange interacting with the regular
Avengers because this is the first time
we've seen the character you have no
idea what it's going to feel like when
he's with all those other characters but
if you didn't already think the Chris
Hemsworth and Benedict Cumberbatch were
super cool they actually improv that
whole scene so when Tom Hiddleston says
that Chris Hemsworth is one of the
funniest actors that he's ever worked
with and he'll finally get a chance to
show it in Thor Ragnarok that just means
that you'll see a little bit of that
dubrow humor that Thor has so let me
know in the comments what do you guys
think about all this craziness is going
to be so awesome
and a lot of you been requesting bonus
videos about Thor's weapons so there
will be a day or two during the week
that I dedicate to MCU video stuff for
the Marvel movies like Avengers videos
stuff for Thor spider-man movies I
haven't quite figured out which day
that's going to be but I'll try to pose
update on the schedule in the next
couple of days be sure to click that
Bell to enable alert so that you don't
miss anything congratulations to last
week's giveaway winner
Anthony Banfield please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details there was a
new round that started in this video I
will be posting some more Avengers
infinity war stuff later this week so
I'll announce the winner whenever I post
that but I've got some more Deadpool
that's coming there's a new injustice to
evil Superman trailers that is crazy
that I will post later tonight so it's
going to be awesome while I'm working on
that get on some of this store
behind-the-scenes it's actually pretty
cool and you can click here to rewatch
that infinity war teaser thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys in the next video